in the united states we're facing a
national
water shortage government-backed
research shows that in a little over 50
years
half of the freshwater basins may not
meet our demands
for this story i'm in my home state of
florida here
the water crisis is real and demanding
positive action
this is silver springs almost half of
florida's fresh water comes from
aquifers like this
natural underground reservoirs that are
topped up by rainfall
but earlier this year wet season
rainfall in the south of the state fell
by 45
and the pressure is mounting as
florida's population grows by around
300 000 people a year our water
situation is
unsustainable
i've come to naples botanical garden a
leader in best practices for conserving
water and horticulture
if i understand correctly up to half of
florida's residential water
goes back into irrigating our gardens
what can we do to make that
more efficient we have about six months
out of the year where we have an
abundance of rainfall
and six months where we have drought
conditions being a botanical garden we
really focus on
selecting plants that are that can take
those cycles of drought
if you do that we can really cut down on
irrigation that's
really climate-friendly gardening and
we're working with
nature is there something we can do at
home
to collect our water protect our water
and reuse it yeah so in my own home i
have rain barrels
when it rains we collect water and i use
that water to water my garden
throughout the dry months of the year
quite often we think of
the environment as something that's out
there we think of the everglades
but really the things that we do in our
own homes that's a part of the
environment our backyard is part of the
environment
[Music]
but it's not just outside where we can
make a difference on
average american families use more than
300 gallons of water every day
and a lot of that is being wasted i'd
love to see how my family can save water
at home
from dripping toilets to faulty faucets
leaks in our homes can lose nearly a
trillion gallons of water
every year just replacing a 50 cent
washer on a faucet can save up to 3 000
gallons of water per year
and many of us still rinse our dirty
dishes under a running faucet before
loading them into the dishwasher
this is a huge waste of water because
you actually need the dishes to be dirty
as the enzymes and the detergent latch
onto food particles to work
effectively we have less water than we
think
but the minute we realize that every
drop is valuable we begin to change our
behavior for the better
whether that's creating a
climate-friendly garden fixing that
leaky faucet
or just not pre-rinsing our dishes it's
these little water-saving measures that
can be done by me and the home
and all of us across america that can
help make a huge difference
for future water security